your identity up until the time when
you're like in your late teens has
literally just been a mashup of
everything in your surroundings it's
been what your parents have told you to
believe it's been what people have said
to you on the playground it's been what
your teachers have said it's been the
media that you've been consuming the
biggest ones are obviously parental and
family influences and then suddenly you
fly the nest and you have to understand
and decide what parts of that identity
do I actually not believe in and not
agree with I'm going to Chuck those
aside what parts of them of that
identity do I really believe in and I
want to really cultivate that and engage
with that and then one of the new things
that are going to come in that perhaps
my parents don't accept and I think a
lot about this in terms of sexual
identity and people discovering that
after leaving conservative homes or your
political affiliation or just your
passions and and what really drives you
all those things need to come together
that is going to take time you're
basically relearning Who You Are